all right yeah thanks so uh
i'm alex i am excited to be a postdoc
here for the semester
so um here's the kinds of problems i'm
interested in let me just give you an
example so finding a fleet in a random
graph
um being a fully connected subgraph like
the one shown in red
there's actually a few different
variants of this question
so detection means i give you a graph
either it's just a random graph
or it has a planted leak in it and you
have to tell me which one it was
we could also talk about recovery that
means i give you a graph with augmented
tweak and you're going to find the
vertices of the clique
uh or we can talk about optimization
this means i give you a random graph
with no time to tweak and you just have
to find the largest tweaks uh as large
as you can
these kinds of problems often have what
we call statistical computational gaps
for a complete example
at the leaf of sinus k and a graph of n
vertices
um and we think about either the
detection or recovery question it turns
out doesn't matter um here's kind of the
phase diagram we have
if i'm willing to kind of brute force
check all the possible tweaks
um i just i can succeed as long as the
leak size is bigger than two log base
two of n that's just the size of the
largest naturally occurring frequency
graph but if i want a polynomial time
algorithm we actually only know these
when
uh the quick sizes
and so in the middle we have kind of
this hard region where we believe it's
fundamentally uh hard there should be no
algorithm and we'd like to kind of
understand why that is and hopefully
understand why that is in a unified way
that applies to all kinds of different
so the logically polynomial method
is one particular framework for trying
to understand these things and
um i'll tell you a bit about it so
historically this originated from the
sum of squares literature
and the idea is kind of quite simple you
just want to study a restricted class of
algorithms namely loaded with
polynomials
so by this i mean a multivariate
polynomial that takes the entire input
uh so right maybe taking a whole graph
with one variable for each edge either
zero one telling you if that pitch is
there
and the output uh depends on the setting
but
maybe for instance the output is
supposed to be like an indicator vector
that is supposed to be
the position of the large space
and when i say low degree you should
have in mind maybe logarithmic degree
depends maybe a little bit on the set
um
so it turns out luckily like lots of
leading algorithmic paradigms can
actually be captured by this kind of
framework for example spectral methods
or power iteration and also approximate
message passing
a few other things
um
and what you know has been realized in
recent years is that maybe amazingly for
a lot of these statistical problems so
these are problems that roughly have
some kind of a signal variance that kind
of noise
um
low degree algorithms actually as
powerful as the best algorithms that we
know
and so i want to talk about the flip
side the lower bounds so how can we
prove that all low degree polynomials
fail to solve the task
the reason we want to do this is because
uh this would constitute some kind of
evidence that the problem is actually
and in particular can be used to
formally rule out specific things like
spectral methods or
amp
um so i want to talk about three
different
types of problems like before a prior
work focused on detection and then i
want to talk about some new work where
we kind of understand that
so let me jump right in
um
detection remember we want to hypothesis
test between two possible distributions
right i give you a graph either it comes
from a null model which is just a random
graph or it comes from a planted model
we want to ask ourselves is there a low
degree polynomial that can solve this
problem
right this means the polynomial that
takes in the whole adjacency matrix
outputs just one number
and what does it mean to succeed we want
that number to hopefully be big if there
is a platform tweak and small if there's
not
um formally this turns out to be the
quantity we try to compute
so it's a maximum over polynomials
because we want the best one
of like the mean value implanted divided
by the size of the fluctuations in q
right so if this thing is big say
tending to infinity
um
this
means in some sense that degree d
polynomials succeed at distinguishing
these two distributions whereas if it is
bounded
this would mean that it is required
uh
no i'm not here but there is like an
equivalent formulation of this that is
yeah there's a similar form of this
where you do restricted be zero it turns
out to happen
so okay two sort of
um
fortuitous things happen here one is
that you can actually compute this thing
using basically just linear algebras
basic binomials
and the second is that this thing
actually
seems to make all the correct
predictions for
these statistical problems pointing
sleek sparse pcas etcetera etcetera
this thing really is big
so that's detection
let me talk quickly about recovery
so here's another problem to motivate my
recovery is important very simple
problem it's an n by n matrix there's a
k by k planted sub matrix somewhere
and everything is gaussian with variance
one except the planted sub matrix has an
elevated v
um okay and the goal is just to find
this matrix
um but i like this problem
has a detection recovery gap and what
this means is that while detection is
quite easy you can just add up all the
entries of the matrix
right because you have this elevated
mean this will help you take it out
under some condition
but if you actually want to recover
actually finding the sub matrix um this
seems to be harder the best way we know
is basically to use the top eigenvector
and this requires some stronger gains
right so recovery seems strictly harder
than detection
and so generally speaking if you can
show detection is hard this means
recovery is hard
so that's one way you could hope to show
recovery is hard
but in this case the real challenge is
how do we show recovery is hard in a
regime where we know detection is easy
right we have to do something other than
leverage the detection harness
yes so we don't know one so you can do
things like correct the mean correct the
variance those don't work they do shrink
the gap a little bit but not all the way
so yeah i don't just i don't i don't
know
about this testing but
there's not like a different null model
you can invest that will close the gap
it seems
unless the null model is something yeah
quite complicated that maybe we wouldn't
be able to analyze anyway
yeah that's a great question
um
and so
okay
but
roughly um for these recovery problems
we do have a way to analyze the
polynomial setting
so imagine you observe something that's
kind of signal plus noise
and the small x is something we want to
estimate say maybe it's just the
indicator that's the first coordinate
um
right this is quantity
how much correlation can a low degree
polynomial get with the thing we want to
estimate uh suitably normalized
um we have a way you know that's a very
natural thing to write down it turns out
to actually bound this we need sort of a
trick where you apply enzymes inequality
only to the signal and not noise and
this somehow simplifies things enough
here
um okay and this now yields uh kind of
tight results for planted sub matrix and
really explains this detection recovery
gap right so this thing tells you that
in the regime where you know recovery is
easy a low degree polynomial does
succeed in a sense whereas in this
regime we think it's hard for
um recovery this thing is not
um
one last setting is optimization
so for example imagine i gave you a
random sparse graph and your goal is
just to find the biggest independent set
that you can so no planted solution
um
this also has kind of a gap like the
actual maximum will be
two times something but the best known
polynomial time algorithms only find
something half an independent set half
is large
um and again we have ways to basically
prove that
you know a constant degree polynomial
can get all the way up to this injection
value l but no low degree polynomial
the proof involves somehow stability of
the degree polynomials along with the
structural property
okay so just to summarize
um hopefully i've convinced you that
slow degree polynomials successfully
explain these statistical computational
gaps in a bunch of different settings
like detection recovery optimization
and the fourth one i didn't talk about
is certification of reputation
um we used a few different techniques
for all of these situations
and uh there's a couple of main
challenges like
uh these are some problems we don't know
how to handle and more generally uh
connecting the various heuristics
yeah thanks that's all